aquí tenemos a esta matriz am y yo lo
que quiero preguntar en esta ocasión es
quién es el espacio columna de a y bueno
quién es el espacio columna de amd eso
ya lo sabemos el espacio columna de amd
es el espacio vectorial generado por los
vectores columnas de la matriz am es
decir por a el espacio vectorial
generado y vamos a ponerles nombre voy a
suponer que este es a 1 este de aquí va
a ser a 2 y bueno este a-3 a-4 y hasta
acá está a 5 entonces el espacio columna
de an es el espacio vectorial generado
por a uno por a dos por a tres por a
cuatro y por a cinco y bueno yo lo que
quiero preguntarme también en este vídeo
es cuál va a ser una base de este
espacio columna de amd porque con esto
voy a poder pensar en cuál es la
dimensión del espacio columna de a y
bueno de hecho sería muy bueno probarlo
en este vídeo aunque no creo que me dé
tiempo pero seguramente en el siguiente
vídeo quiero demostrar t este método
para encontrar una
del espacio columna de a y bueno pero
después de todo esto lo que me gustaría
recordar es que es una base del espacio
columna de a en general que es una base
bueno para hacer una base lo que
necesitamos es que sea el espacio
vectorial generado por estos vectores lo
cual pues lo sabemos porque justamente
esta es la definición del espacio
columna de amd y además necesitamos que
sean linealmente independientes
linealmente independientes y es justo
eso lo que no sabemos para que esto se
convierta en una base este conjunto
tendría que ser linealmente
independiente y curiosamente es lo que
no sabemos pero bueno para encontrar
esta base del espacio columna de amd el
procedimiento es el siguiente lo primero
que hay que encontrar es la forma
escalonada de la matriz a así que vamos
a trabajar con la forma escalonada de la
matriz am y para esto voy a dejar el
primer renglón del cualquiera que me
mejor ponerlo por acá porque son muchos
renglones voy a poner el primer en donde
el cual aquí 10 menos 10 4 y ahora en
lugar de en redondo os voy a poner el
renglón 2 - dos veces el renglón
así que manos a la obra es decir me voy
a tomar el renglón 2 y le voy a quitar
dos veces se atan los 1 y me queda 2 -
2010 es uno después 0 menos 20 menos
menos 2 es decir 0 más dos es 2
aquí me queda 20 menos 2 por 0 es 09 - 2
por 4 es 8 por lo tanto me queda un 1 y
bueno en este tercer renglón en lugar de
poner este tercer renglón voy a poner a
que me quiera poner el tercer renglón
más el primer renglón de tal manera que
me quedan menos 110 20 25 menos uno es
455 menos uno es 4 1 - 0 pues esto es 1
y por último menos 54 lo cual me da
menos 1 y bueno en este último renglón
lo que voy a hacer es tomarme el rendón
número 4 - el renglón número 1 de tal
manera que me va a quedar 1 - 1 pero uno
menos uno es cero
1 - 0 - 1 - 0
1 - 3 - 1 esto es lo mismo que menos 2
menos 3 más unos menos 2 - 2 - 0 pues
esto es menos 2 esto está muy sencillo y
9 menos 4 5 muy bien ya tengo el primer
paso porque al final
ya tengo abajo de este primer 1 puros
ceros vamos bien ahora ya tenemos a una
variable pivote o a una columna pivote y
ahora lo que necesito es que estos dos
de aquí abajo sean a cero porque aquí ya
tenemos un cero entonces me quedaría 10
menos 10 4 aquí me queda lo mismo para
hacer esta variable pivote
012011 perfecto y ahora lo que quiero es
que estos dos de aquí se hagan cero por
lo tanto voy a tener que eliminar este 2
y para esto lo voy a tomar el renglón 3
- dos veces el renglón 2 y que me queda
de esto bueno pues no debe quedar 0
después 2 - 2 me da cero
4 - 4 pues esto es 0 también después
1 - 0 pues esto es 1 y por último menos
uno más
2 - 1 - 2 esto es menos 3 muy bien y
ahora lo que tengo que hacer es que
también este último renglón aquí me
quede 0 para que se convierta este 1 en
una variable pívot y para esto me voy a
tomar el renglón 4 más
el renglón 2 es este fácil entonces me
queda 0 después de aquí menos uno más
uno es cero menos dos más dos también es
0 - 2 + 0 pues esto es menos 2 y por
último 5 más 1 esto es 6 muy bien 5 1 es
6 y ahora date cuenta de cómo va
quedando todo esto va bien parece que
todo va en orden porque fíjate aquí ya
tengo este de aquí es una variable
pivote este de que es otra variable el
pívot en este pues aquí no voy a tener
variables pivote sin embargo ahora lo
que quiero es que este este y este
también sea una variable pivote y para
hacer esta una variable pivote lo que
tengo que hacer es pues quitar este 2 de
aquí me ponen un cero y para quitar este
2 de aquí y poner un cero lo que
a hacer es poner todo aquí lo primero
que voy a hacer es copiar todo lo que la
información que ya tengo es 10 - 10 4 10
-1 04 01 2010 12 01 00 01 - 13 0 0 0 1 2
3 y ahora en lugar de poner el renglón 4
voy a poner a el renglón cuatro más dos
veces el renglón 3 de tal manera que que
me va a quedar 0 0 después menos 2 más 2
pues esto va a ser cero también y por
último 6 más menos 3 por 2 lo cual
también es 0 y bueno no hay que
preocuparnos porque ya por fin aquí
tengo mi forma escalonada de la matriz a
este de aquí este de jan poner lo mejor
este es mi forma escalonada de la matriz
a que para hacerlo mucho más fácil le
voy a poner el nombre de r así que
déjenme apuntarlo aquí esta es la forma
escalonada de la matriz a lo voy a poner
aquí la forma escalonada de la maté
que para los cuates es r así que eres
igual a esta matriz muy bien que por
cierto ya tengo mis variables private lo
que quiero que te des cuenta es que aquí
ya tengo tres variables pivote esta de
aquí es una columna pivote esto de aquí
es una columna pivote está nombre sin
embargo esta también es una columna
pivote porque date cuenta que hay un 1
en puro ceros después otro 1 y puro
ceros y por último otro 1 y puro ceros y
por esto estas son mis tres columnas
pivote ahora si les ponemos su nombre no
sea éste le voy a llamar r 1 a esto es
lo voy a llamar r2 y r3 r4 y r7 r1 r2 r3
y por lo tanto este sería r 4 lo que
quiero que veas es que el conjunto
formado por r1 r2 y r4 es un conjunto de
vectores linealmente independiente éste
es un conjunto de vectores linealmente
independiente y eso nos va a servir
bastante pero antes fíjate que es
linealmente independiente porque aquí
tengo un 1 y no hay ninguna forma de
formar este uno con este 0 y con este
otro 0 dicho
si yo aquí tengo uno en este componente
no hay ninguna combinación lineal de r2
y de r 4 de tal manera que me dé un 1
aquí porque por ejemplo yo pongo 300 por
0 + menos 3 por 0 pues esto va a ser
cero y nunca me va a dar 1 para lo que
sea esto nunca me va a dar 1 por lo
tanto necesitamos a este vector que
tenemos aquí y por lo tanto entraría en
un conjunto de linealmente independiente
sin embargo ahora nos fijamos en el en
el siguiente vector en r2 y qué creés
con r 2 pasa algo muy parecido porque
aquí tenemos un 1 y después tenemos dos
ceros aquí al lado por lo tanto no hay
forma de que nos tomemos una combinación
lineal con r1 y r4 para que me dé r2 y
de igual manera para r4 por lo tanto
aquí estamos viendo que r1 r2 y r4 son
idealmente independientes y de hecho
pues es la definición de columnas pivote
las columnas pivotes siempre va a ser
linealmente independientes y ahora si lo
regresamos la matriz a que cree es éstas
que son nuestras columnas asociadas a
estas columnas pivotes son también
linealmente independientes ojo ahorita
no he demostrado
había eso déjame aquí ponerles el
círculo muy bien y aquí lo voy a poner
connotación de conjuntos a 1 a 2 a 4
estas cuatro columnas son linealmente
independientes y bueno ahorita todavía
no lo he demostrado sin embargo justo en
el vídeo siguiente lo que voy a hacer es
precisamente demostrar esto que si
nosotros aplicamos todas las operaciones
para llegar a la forma escalonada de la
matriz am esto no afecta que estos
vectores sean linealmente independientes
por lo tanto por ahorita quiero que me
creas esto y ahora para que fueran una
base del espacio columna de amd lo que
quiero que veas es que ya tenemos que
son linealmente independientes pero lo
que sí vemos bueno preguntarnos es si
generan el espacio vectorial generado
por estos cinco vectores es decir que si
podemos prescindir de este vector y de
este otro vector y fíjate que este
vector y este vector están asociados a
estos vectores columna que no eran
vectores pivote por lo tanto lo que
quiero decirte en este momento es algo
muy importante y también lo voy a probar
en el siguiente vídeo cuando yo tengo a
mis vectores pivote a mis vectores
columna pivote y estos forman
linealmente independiente entonces
cuando yo me regreso la matriz am
estos son ni más ni menos que la base
del espacio columna de a podemos
entonces prescindir de estos dos
vectores columna a tres ya cinco porque
el espacio vectorial generado por a uno
por actos y por a cuatro es el espacio
vectorial generado también por a1 a2 a3
a4 y a5 es decir que cualquier
combinación lineal que obtenga con estos
cinco vectores la pueda encontrar
también con una combinación lineal de
estos tres vectores pivote esto es
también padre porque aunque no lo ha
demostrado estoy diciendo que estos
vectores columna pivote son muy
importantes porque me dan mi base del
espacio columna de a y más aún este
vector a tres y este vector a cinco los
puedo generar con una combinación lineal
de a uno a dos y ya cuatro por lo tanto
esta es exactamente la respuesta debe
encontrar una base para un espacio
columna
ahora quiero preguntarme otra cosa ya sé
y eso lo voy a apuntar aquí ya sé que la
base del espacio columna de unos
vectores a 1 a 2 a 4 los vectores
columna de amd
estos tres vectores columna de amd
forman mi base del espacio columna de a
es decir que dejamos fuera a estos dos
estos dos no están ahora si yo me quiero
preguntar sobre la dimensión del espacio
columna de amd y déjame contarlo aquí yo
lo que quiero a ver ahora es cuál es la
dimensión del espacio columna de amd y
bueno habíamos dicho que la dimensión de
un sub espacio es la cantidad de
elementos que tenía la base del psuv
espacio es decir si yo quiero calcular
la dimensión del espacio columna de amd
pues tengo que contar que tengo tres
elementos a uno a dos ya cuatro y esto
es lo que se conoce como la dimensión
del espacio columna de ambos que por
cierto tiene un nombre especial se llama
el rango
el rango de a no es ni más ni menos que
exactamente lo mismo que la dimensión
del espacio columna de a es decir tres y
bueno entonces regresemos a esta idea si
yo quiero saber el rango de am lo que
tengo que ver es cuáles son mis vectores
columna que forman una base del espacio
columna de am es decir un conjunto que
fuera linealmente independiente y además
que generará el espacio columna de a y
para hacer esto lo que hicimos fue
encontrar la forma escalonada de la
matriz am y aquí encontrar cuáles sean
los vectores columna pivote de esta
forma escalonada de la matriz a los
cuales nos ayudaban a encontrar
precisamente los vectores columna
asociados a ellos y justo eso es lo que
voy a ver en el siguiente vídeo
voy a demostrar que esto siempre sirve y
además queda pendiente de mostrar
también que este conjunto genera a todo
el espacio columna de a